it's on streets like these where rising
bills really bite
abdul spends as much spare time as he
has delivering food parcels to people in
bradford
you got your milk you've got your bread
everything in there
he says the number of calls have nearly
doubled since this time last year even
as we drive around they keep coming
i mean i'm getting calls through nine
ten o'clock in the evening people have
just got nothing in their fridges they
say they
buy some food
or hit their house up
they have no choice
there we go ma
keller he knows a hike in energy bills
will be crippling to people like emma
but the price cap in place to protect
people is set to rise by as much as 50
percent
emma can't afford to heat the house
often when she does it doesn't last long
it stays warm for about 10-15 minutes
and then that's it
even if we're under quilt we have hot
water bottle it's still cold and we just
sit there shaking and everything
generally these terraced houses were
built for during the industrial
revolution in this part of the world
poorly insulated homes are occupied by
people on low wages it is the perfect
cocktail for fuel poverty
the government's planning to help with a
loan scheme up to 200 pounds per
household but the underlying drivers say
experts remain they tend to have
uninsulated walls limited insulation in
the roof and then also no insulation in
the floor and those things mean that
they're fairly leaky from an energy
perspective there are already many
people in this country who struggle to
heat their homes particularly if those
homes are of poorer quality but this
latest increase in prices could push as
many as a quarter of uk households into
fuel poverty rising bills will affect
millions of us but they'll bite the
hardest for those with the fewest
choices
and that includes the option to move on
embarking in dagenham there aren't
enough permanent homes aleph jane and
her family are stuck here while they
wait for one you can see
mould the dump and cold are so bad the
walls literally drip with condensation
mold grows everywhere i did just to
mention clean up on
saturday warming this place is expensive
and she's worried
this whole month i've i've struggled
i've put in whatever i can afford and
that could be like two pounds to four
pounds
two
highest will be ten or fifteen pounds
but then that would mean i'll have to
take something off my budget so one less
thing for the kids
millions of households could soon face
energy bills of around 2000 pounds a
year whether that much can be managed
depends a lot on who you are and where
you live helen and smith sky news